hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well human beings are
according to the Stoics social creatures
that is we exist in a whole fabric of
various relationships not only family
relationships that were born into or
enter into through some sort of ceremony
like marriage becoming one brother or
somebody but also all sorts of other
webs of relationships think about our
workplaces the people that we travel
with the people that we live in
proximity to there's a whole bunch of
things people on the internet comprise
communities as well and the Stoics
were concerned with how it is that we
connect up with with other people I've
got other videos about you know
performing our social roles so this
isn't really so much about that rather a
concern that epictetus expresses about
what we're calling here social
intercourse is a decent way to translate
some theory for us right for us means
sort of like carrying or conducting
yourself swimming together with Perry
around you know so think about this is
like however we're doing things in
proximity with other people along with
them that's rad
when didn't way of saying it but kind of
gets in it so social intercourse social
engagements are social connections and
the issue is we can often get ourselves
in trouble if we are trying to live this
topics by falling into the same sort of
patterns of behavior as other people do
because we want to say hang out with
them or we want to be part of their
group or we want to spend time with them
and that's the way in which we do it so
if we've got for example a parent who's
constantly watching TV it's going to be
difficult to take them out to the park
and have a nice conversation over coffee
there because what they want you to do
is sit your butt down on on the couch
next to them and watch TV and maybe chat
about what's what's happening on the
screen and you know we can see things
similarly about all sorts of other
pursuits
Epictetus has the example of drinking
friends right the people that you drink
with if you say I don't feel like
drinking today not so much in common
with you anymore and we find you know
similar things sometimes in terms of
people wanting to talk shop who work in
the same place and somebody else say I
want to talk shop you know they go out
to the bar let's talk about something
else and suddenly nobody really has
anything to talk about so they go back
to talking shop so Epictetus thinks that
it's very important not to allow oneself
to be as we say drawn in or dragged down
by other people these are two nice very
visual metaphors somebody draws us in to
the activity that they're involved with
something drags us down to their level
he says this is very important says to
this topic you want to devote yourself
before every other namely how you may
avoid ever being so intimately
associated with someone of your
acquaintances or friends as to descended
the same level with him otherwise you're
going to ruin yourself and then he says
why do people do this that if it's
unreasonable if it's imprudent
I mean Stoics and we don't to be
studying opportunist
that the company we keep tends to rub
off on us and there's probably some
people whose company we should avoid
because there are trouble right
not just with friends but even with
relationships you know you have a friend
that gets involved with with some
boyfriend or girlfriend like wow they're
bad news they're starting to rub up on
here why is it difficult for them to see
that and to respond appropriately to
that well there's three main things that
he considers one is the fear of not
appearing let's get them out of there
the fear of appearing unwelcoming
great word for that is I get seals
therefore my Institute's a welcome to
take in an unfriendly so you know when
somebody wants to do stuff with us and
they offer us the chance to do it say
this is what we do it seems like we're
kind of being jerked by by not doing
that we have to make a choice and this
choice is for us we'll often a tough one
that the fact that it is a tough one is
a sign of two things one just how strong
social bonds really are and to the fact
that we haven't made as much progress as
we'd like to make because it would be an
easy choice for us if yeah so what we
have to do is we have to think about
what are the results for either choice
it's up to us do we mix ourselves in
with these other people do we get
involved but can hold ourselves back do
we say I'm sorry but I can't go along
with that sort of thing whatever we do
it's going to bear some consequences for
us so he says nothing is done that I'm
paying for it it's impossible for a man
to remain the same person he used to be
if he does not do the same things
choose therefore which you prefer here's
one possibility either to be lost just
as much as you used to buy the same
person's remaining like your former self
or by being superior to your former self
to lose this
affection you can't keep both of them he
says you can try to keep both of them
and then you're probably not going to
get either one and we've seen people
like that or they're like yeah you know
I'm changing my lifestyle and I'll still
hang out with all of you but I can't
really participate in anything that
you're doing I still really enjoy your
company but I just don't approve of
anything that you do that doesn't really
work for you you lose the affection and
I'm probably you're gonna fall back into
the same patterns
Epictetus would often suggest in some
cases making a clean break
he says if this latter alternative to
lose the infection is the better choice
then turn in that direction and don't
let the other considerations draw you
away because you can't make progress
when you're facing both directions but
if you preferred this course to every
other or you wish to devote yourself to
this alone and labor to perfect it give
up everything else otherwise you're
gonna have a double result it will
neither make progress normal you get
what you used to before for before when
you frankly aimed at nothing worthwhile
you at least made a pleasant companion
you know if we're gonna just you know
live it up and you know take it easy and
get into trouble sometimes
then if we're gonna do that we may
little just do it right and not have a
whole bunch of qualms about it because
at least then we're committed to
something so he says you can't achieve
distinction along both of these lines
you have to fall short in one or the
other if you don't drink with those who
you used to drink with you cannot be in
their eyes as pleasant a companion as
you used to be
it just isn't going to work choose
whether you want to be a hard drinker
and pleasant to those persons or a sober
person and unpleasant to those persons
you can't count on both either you can
drink with them or you can make progress
either you can you know do whatever it
is that these people over here are doing
that you know isn't the right thing to
do and they probably have some sense
it's not the right thing or you can make
progress you cannot have both of these
he says if you don't sing with those who
used to sing with you cannot be loved by
them as you used to and so on you know
as with all sorts of other things he
says give up other considerations
renounce them turn your back on them you
have nothing to do with them but if that
doesn't please you then turn around
become you know one of these people who
does those other things jump up and
shout your applause for the dancers the
different characters don't mix in this
fashion you cannot be the curb who uses
an example here of both their cities and
an amendment you can't be this guy and
that guy at the same time you got to
make a choice and so you know there's a
lot of cases where we're going to have
forced choices like that particularly
considering the cards that we get dealt
with people that we know right but the
good news is this we can choose other
people we can find other activities that
aren't going to raise these sorts of
problems with us if we want to make
progress
probably we have to try to find social
connections that are going to support
that progress instead of holding it back
he's got a really great example of
something a bit more specific than
chapter 13 where he's talking about
people who are too open about private
matters and this is a common problem in
our own day it was a common problem in
that back to this day you know when we
say TMI too much information
we're signifying that sort of thing he
says when someone gives us the
impression of having talked to us
frankly about his personal affairs
somehow or other we're like why I'd like
to tell them our own secrets and to
think that that is frankness that is
being straightforward that's being a a
good person and why is that this is one
of the problems that social intercourse
believes in - well we have to ask
yourself is it unfair to not be equally
forthcoming if somebody makes admissions
or confidences to us do we have you know
is it only fear if we say something in
return to them if we don't do that will
we be viewed as unfriendly
or as unsocial that's not
problem another third one that he brings
up that's really interesting we tend to
think that if somebody is making
admissions yeah you know not a really a
good herd tonight
I had kicked a dog last week and slashed
somebody's tires and every once in a
while I steal the Social Security checks
out so it's those mailbox we did some
other things that that makes them more
trustworthy and then we should therefore
trust them because they're trusting us
with a secret because you know we could
hurt them and that pigs insects this is
terrible logic you know it is not a sign
of trust it's actually a sign of
something else so he says let's to
consider the first reason it seems
unfair for a man to have hurt his
neighbor's affairs and not to let him
have it is trying to share it in ours so
you know isn't really unfair and so he
considers that he says isn't it is it
fair to hear your neighbors secrets and
then give him no share of your own he
says look buddy I didn't invite your
confidences did I you didn't tell me
about your affairs on certain conditions
that you were to hear about mine in
return if you're a gambler and think
that every person you meet is a friend
you want me to be like yourself you're
imprudent buddy
the same man but I am using funny so
you're in the prudent and you think that
I should be imprudent because you can't
keep your mouth shut because you reveal
stuff about yourself you probably should
keep to yourself when you're dealing
with strangers or acquaintances that's
kind of crazy logic you say so I don't
have to do that what about the second
one are we going to be viewed as
unfriendly or social well that same
thing applies here we've got a sign did
we want this person to like us is that
really that important to us or do we
want to make progress do we want to stay
on the path of progress probably this
person who's making imprudent
confessions to us is not the kind of
person whose affection we really need
and it would be kind of silly for us to
think yeah I have to get in with that
because they were telling me all sorts
of stuff about themselves now think
about that the last one is this really a
sign of being trustworthy he says here's
here's what the person could say I trust
you
you don't trust me and then he says
first of all you don't trust me you
you're just a bad learner that's why you
can't keep anything back look at
yourself if that statement of yours is
true that in trust these manners to me
alone but the fact is whenever you see
anybody you sit down beside them and you
say brother I have no one more kindly
disposed or dearer to me than you I ask
you to listen to my affairs and you may
act this way the people that you've not
known for even a short time so even if
you do trust me it's not clear that you
trust me as a faithful and respectful
person not because I've already told you
about my affairs so let me have the same
thought about you show me that if a
person opens himself up about his own
affairs he's actually faithful and
respectful and that reasoning doesn't
actually follow up he's saying look show
me something that can't actually be
demonstrated namely that opening up and
talking about all sorts of things at
random with strangers is a good thing
and a sign of being trustworthy as a
matter of fact it's probably a sign that
they're not trustworthy why would you
talk to somebody who is such a
blabbermouth about something that is is
secret or private or proprietary to
yourself do you know that they're going
to talk about it with other people so
this is a good example of the kind of
trap that people sometimes fall into
when they're getting involved with with
acquaintances in social intercourse you
know sitting next to somebody at the
game sitting next to somebody on the bus
involved in some sort of meeting with a
co-worker right in a team-building
activity these are the sorts of issues
that often tend to arise so epictetus
thinks we need to devote considerable
thought and attention and make some
important and hard choices when it comes
to who we choose as our companions and
how far were willing to go with them